somebody came into the courtroom and
said that your character jenkins
wouldn't be wearing that in court and
you just casually on your phone showed a
picture of jenkins in court wearing that
very outfit
and you did the research you knew
exactly what you were going to be doing
that day you knew the character better
than in some ways better than we knew it
after researching it for two years
[Music]
as you'll see very very quickly i ain't
[ __ ] walter cronkite like you know
it's not what you know i'm doing this
for for a very sort of specific reason
uh trying to bring folks in and talk to
folks that uh i admire deeply and that i
respect greatly and i think are sort of
a model
of of what they do and people who who
walk the walk don't just talk about it
and uh so they but they get maxed i
never really do like proper
introductions but you know look man you
know you're you're one of the greatest
american writers of all time you know
and and everybody
and you've been
you you know just today i was reading
you know you've been compared to to
faulkner you've been compared to twain
you've been complaining it's like i
don't think so well it's funny because
they just told me not to say that
because dennis was like told me you
would be like john go [ __ ] yourself shut
up but it's true well i actually don't
think i've ever been
i'll show you the article man i
shouldn't my i was like hey pop i get
you know with that kind of research
stuff i always ask my dad i told you my
dad's like a huge fan of yours and uh
like huge fan you know you're his
favorite writer and so i asked him to
like and uh you know and he was and i'll
show you the article man you were
compared to anne chandler i uh yeah uh
but look i i i you know you've been a dc
guy your your whole life yeah um we both
you know grew up right here in the city
and i just i guess like just
first and foremost just tell me a little
bit about
growing up in dc what you love about the
city and all that well i you know i'm uh
fortunate in a lot of ways and one of
them i think is that i i
i grew up in a time sort of straddle
different eras and so i remember
washington before
16 everybody in dc that's lived here a
long time breaks it up before 1968 and
after 1968 because of the because of the
riots the riots yeah that followed in in
the wake of the um dr king's
assassination i mean i always say that
the riots
however much destruction and negativity
are associated with it with the riots
it accelerated the civil rights movement
by 10 years in one weekend wow and it's
where dr king was going too he was not
you know a lot of a columnist now right
right wing type columnist will say
always say that's not what dr king
wanted first of all how do you know what
he wanted yeah and there's all
indications that towards the end of his
life
he was getting fed up with um
100 peaceful
uh protests what were some of those
indications like what i mean i think in
some of his speeches he was starting to
say uh well
the the actual
speech that he gave at the national
cathedral
which i i'll get back to that but i saw
it
um
he said something like i fear that if
things don't change very quickly
this summer meaning the coming summer
we're gonna see some violence those
weren't his exact words but he predicted
it yeah
and he was also coming out very strongly
against the vietnam war his focus was
changing into a broader sort of
type of protest of
the uh american government in in all
respects not just in in racial relations
but
their actions overseas and so on he was
changing yeah
that sunday i came out of saint sophia
greek orthodox cathedral was my church
and i heard a guy's voice i heard a
man's voice coming out over loudspeakers
and i walked across the street and i
walked behind the
cathedral which is right there
into the gardens and all that and there
was like a thousand people back there
yeah and i stood back there with the
people and i listened to dr king speak
and i didn't know
i didn't understand really what he was
talking about how old were you i was 11.
but i could see on the people's faces
that he what he was what he meant
to people because they were
there he had their wrapped attention
yeah and then four days later he was
assassinated
wow and the riots came
so that you know all that
uh that that year and that summer and me
going down there and working for my
father and my dad obviously is a greek
guy and then all black employees about
five people that they're long-time
employees on the other side of the
counter white people
wearing ties like professionals did that
change after the rides no but well yeah
i mean there we had black customers but
for the most part it was white people
white professionals wearing ties mostly
men sitting at that counter
and that counter
was
symbolic to me um on a not on an
intellectual level but i felt
what side of the counter was i on
you were you you were you're in the back
i was on the side with my father and his
help yeah
and um
everything i've written about has come
from that wow that's what that's what
sparked me to be a writer wow i didn't
understand it but i knew that there was
something there i mean just that time in
dc and then going into the 70s
like it just must have been just a crate
i mean it
like night and day difference then i
mean what what what sort of the city
became and like what what was that like
it's like coming into being a teenager
growing up around here yeah it was just
it was cool yeah i you know i i i love
to be out there i love playing
basketball pick up basketball or the
city yeah
where'd you play ball at well any place
we would drive around and just find
games you and your friends yeah who are
your friends guy uh you know a bunch of
ethnic guys greek guys
jewish italian
and and uh but you you had a nickname
not so later okay and what was the
nickname well shoe dog shoe dog yeah
yeah yeah right on well what was your
game like man uh just uh i wasn't i
wasn't great but i had heart yeah
scrappy yeah i could see that yeah i
mean i i really one of the things i
wanted to do when i grew up was was play
basketball and i never grew up like i
mean i never grew taller yeah yeah yeah
yeah i had to give up that dream real
fast and talk about just a little bit
like basketball basketball in this city
i grew up in a basketball family my dad
played in college you know my little
brother played in college my dad had a
sunday morning game still has a sunday
morning game it's been going since it's
been going since 1972. and uh you know
if you were if you were in my dad's
house it didn't matter man you like you
literally you could walk in from the
bars at 6am if you slept in that house
he was waking your ass up you were
playing basketball at 7 30. like you had
no choice
uh sounds like fun yeah dude i mean
you know i got to say that the the i'm
i'm getting to be an old guy you know
like i'm 64 years old and one of the
only things that i
i really hate about is i can't play
basketball anymore
it didn't happen yesterday it happened
like you know when i got into my 50s
and and i have dreams about playing
basketball and i
like getting into games and and that's
the only way i can play anymore what do
you love about like what do you miss
about it i just
to me there was nothing better than than
than playing a game of basketball with
guys even guys you didn't know
especially and and going after it you
know trying to win we used to play for
push-ups i don't know if you guys ever
did that but yeah i mean i mean you know
i mean really for us it was just like
talking [ __ ] bragging rights and then
like people you know you had courts that
you kind of claimed and stuff like that
my old man always talks about how you
can get a guy on a basketball court you
can tell anything about him you can
judge their character in like two
seconds do you feel the same
i i know what he's talking about yeah
you know it's like if a guy shoots all
the time or if he wants to work the ball
do you hustle you so i i guess when i
asked about your game you screwed like
what would be the strengths of your game
would you say
i mean i surprised people i could go to
the hoop yeah you know
that was a surprise because i'm not i'm
not big at all yeah yeah yeah average
yeah yeah um
and uh and you know but i like to dish
too uh uh let's set stuff up i saw as
far as like the racial dynamic of this
city and like how the city the the the
kind of character of the city is there
anything like specifically basketball
um did you find that as like a great
equalizer did you find when you went to
court sometimes that you weren't really
accepted well both but i i do feel like
sports and work are two places where
that's where you meet people who aren't
like you you know
and and that's
that's really and of course sports is a
meritocracy so
you can prove yourself out there or not
it doesn't matter who your father is
absolutely
um
but that's where i met
that's where i met a lot of people that
weren't you know from my neighborhood
was sports yeah and then on the job
and i always worked these fun jobs like
uh even when i when i wasn't working for
my dad i ended up doing a lot of retail
and then in my 20s i worked in bars and
kitchens and things like that
and i couldn't wait to get to work i
mean the reason was the shoe dog
nickname is i worked at a place called
the bootlegger during uh collet during
college
here with there was these they had a few
shoe stores in dc
and they were um
catered to they were the beautiful shoes
it's the best shoes in washington so we
got the best-looking women coming in
there okay and they hired like all guys
to work the floor
and
you know for obvious reasons and it was
the most fun job i i ever had like
even today like if you said well could i
go back and work on that shoe
floor again i'd give up everything that
i've done
it's true i mean it was just amazing and
but also you know that there you learn a
lot about people there too because it
was straight commission it was really uh
competitive very competitive
and um
it was it was so much fun and you know
you know in your your teenage day i mean
we've talked about a little bit and then
and you know i've just heard some things
you know obviously i'm i'm close with
you know one of your sons but you got
into uh a fair bit of trouble
as well as a young man uh can you just
talk to me sort of about that and about
like
kind of uh the kind of things that you
were getting into and just describe sort
of that part of your life and why you
think you were making those kinds of
decisions um
well i'll i'll talk about it in in the
context of why i uh
do a lot of things that i do now in
other words why i
i've been for a long time i go into
juvenile detention places and i go into
the dc jail and i do these writing
programs and reading programs and stuff
like that i've been very fortunate in a
lot of ways first of all
i grew up in a house where i had
everything i needed and i'm not talking
about money because we we didn't have
money but
you know food shelter love you know
that's all you need that's i firmly
believe that that's all kid needs
so i had that but
i being a boy i you know i was attracted
to the other side of life and i i
screwed up cut quite a bit and you know
so like there was a lot of things i'm
not going to detail everything but and
i'm not even going to say that it was
when i was just a kid because when i was
28 i got arrested for a lot of things
that happened one night
started out with an altercation in a
parking lot it ended with uh
the police chasing me a high-speed chase
and i got charged with a whole rack of
stuff um
you know assault fleeing and eluding the
police driving on the sidewalk
all kinds of things like that
and i was 28 so i can't even chalk that
up to being a kid right you know exactly
what you mean man and
but i didn't get i didn't get sent to
jail
the fact that you didn't get in trouble
that you didn't get put in the system
that you that you still were i imagine
you're you're old man still support the
police they called me the next day
because i i lost them that night i lost
them in that chase i knew that i knew
the streets and they didn't know those
streets so
they called me and they said you know we
got your license number like
you want to come in or he wants to come
get you so i drove to my parents house
and i said mom i was getting ready to
get married in a few months what the
[ __ ] and and i said uh mom dad you know
i'm about to go in and get arrested and
stuff like that i had to do that i went
in there because they didn't catch me
and i was i was
drunk and and there was i'm pretty sure
there was cocaine involved too because
it was the 80s and
i was doing that too and um
because they didn't catch me that night
it was they couldn't get me on the the
substance stuff yeah drunk driving and
everything
so i didn't go to jail
i but i got put in they maybe go to this
thing at night where i went with all
these other people like me
and i took a i took a look around in
that class and there was guys like
you know carving swastikas under the
desk and all that [ __ ] and the first
thing that i thought was
man these guys are a bunch of losers you
know yeah but then the second thing i
thought was i'm one of them
i'm i'm sitting with them i'm not the
guy at the front of the class i'm one of
these guys yeah
yeah and then it woke me up man so that
was your moment right there and that's
but but whatever happened from you know
whatever was going on up until there
you're still talking about like there's
there's a long period of time where i
imagine you were in situations where you
could have learned that lesson where you
for other people it wasn't ready yet it
wasn't ready you could have hit that
rock i mean i i very very similar thing
with with me it was just like it kept
happening i think my last one i think my
last one actually was in in my 30s which
is horribly embarrassing but it was just
one time i saw it you know and and that
was it uh i don't know i don't know what
the word is whether it's some sort of
guilt or some sort of injustice in the
fact that you were able to kind of do
these things these things happened and
you didn't get thrown into the system
what do you want to call it blind luck
whether you want to call it prejudice
whatever it is that you didn't and
you're living in a city where kids are
getting locked up left and right
sometimes for [ __ ] they didn't exactly i
mean you hit it right on the head like
they they came into my house
into a white house
they saw that i was there with two
loving parents and uh
and they're like
we're not gonna do we're not gonna
charge this kid you know yeah yeah i
think probably the same thing
uh i had a lawyer for that last incident
we'll skip right to that
where a lot of people can't get a lawyer
other than a disinterested public
defender
and you know i walked in there with
wearing a suit
and i had a job and all that stuff and
the judge probably looked at me and said
this guy's this guy's not a not an
[ __ ] you know i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna and and but
most of the kids don't even know to to
to go in there and put a tie on it or
get a haircut you know what i mean right
and that's that's what takes me to what
i the reason i'm willing to talk about
this stuff is because
that's why i know they're there but for
the grace of god go i like
those kids that are not all of them
there's some bad kids and that are
sociopaths and stuff like that but for
the most part
they're just like me they they were
stupid boys who uh did stupid things
because their heads are scrambled you
know
and there's a science to it too like
they take pictures of the brain and they
show that a
a 17 year old kid
the the brain is crowded with like
confusion you know the the colors and
everything
and then it you take a picture of that
same brain
five years later and its conscience and
reasoning have taken over you know the
color codes for that yeah have dominate
then dominated the brain that you grow
up yeah
and um
so then i that's when i started going
into uh
i started in dc schools and then i said
well there's kids
in school that are at
oak hill and newbie which became new
beginnings
they have a school there too i should go
out there and talk to those kids and
then i started going through the free
minds book club this organization here
in town i started going and talking to
juveniles the juvenile block at the dc
jail
which is for kids that have committed
really serious crimes and they're
getting ready to transition into the uh
federal prison system when they turn 18
i do this reading program there through
the uh free minds book club did you say
in the moment while i know the same [ __ ]
isn't happening to this guy this guy or
this guy and i just got lucky here is it
something you knew inherently or is it
something that you understood kind of
looking back on it
it's yeah i do i think it's more looking
back on it and
and going to these places and and
getting involved
uh i i you know i don't want to sound
like i'm uh like i'm uh you know rosa
parks or something like that like i'm
doing some great thing
i
you know there's a amount of guilt to it
too because i go to the dc jail and or i
go to new beginnings and then i'm there
for an hour and then i walk out to my
nice car and
you know what i mean i know exactly like
i can't really i can't really help them
in in a way that i that i want to and
and and i don't even have the commitment
to do that
honestly
but
once you do go in there and you get to
know some of these people the young guys
especially
they they know what they did and they
know what they're facing
and i've
had i have more attentive meetings with
those
young people than i do when i go into
public schools and private schools like
this one yeah yeah they they
they're more receptive too there's a
hunger for it yeah there's all that
connection yeah you're gonna look at me
i'm gonna look at you right yeah i mean
during the 80s it was a it was just you
know it was a pretty brutal brutal time
when you talk about crack and aids it
turned
yeah i mean it was just like talk a
little bit about
dc in the 80s you know with you know
being in mayor berries dc
was that a dark time for you or was it
fun as [ __ ] like what what was that like
and and also i guess like in that period
of time where you were getting in
trouble did you know there was more to
life for you did you know that that like
you you were you were kind of better
than that or there there was something
bigger or were you just having fun or
did you not really think about it like
that
uh the 70s was a lot of fun just
straight up fun yeah here yeah
you didn't
you didn't really worry about
random [ __ ] happening to you like
catching a bullet when you're on the
street or
there you know you always got tested
there were fights and stuff but it was
physical fights it was
and and the and the other side even the
drugs were better like it was communal
like you smoked weed with your friends
yeah in the 80s people went in the
bathroom by themselves and did coke yeah
and like that's no fun yeah
and and and also aids came in the 80s so
like before that it was like people in
the 70s you didn't even use condoms yeah
yeah like
you just assumed well she's on the pill
and you're good you're good yeah i mean
it's just it was just fun and then it
kind of like i always think of the 80s
it's like you're climbing up this
mountain in the 70s and then you got to
go down the other side of the mountain
in the 80s and the other side of the
mountain the sun's not shining on it you
know what i mean
i don't i didn't like that decade at all
i had good things happen to me i got
married and and uh
things like that but i didn't i don't
look at it fondly and and it's when
the uh they started coming down on
people for
the three strikes thing all that and
that's
what
we you know we continue to write about
like in our show which is the effect of
the drug war on people
locking people up for non-violent crimes
that's kind of where i was going like do
you do you feel like the 80s and sort of
the
the beginning of the war on drugs
through all your writing
and everything you've done on tvn and
novels
i i try to i try to write about it and
and i feel like i'm in my novels and
feel like i'm
kind of leaving a history of this town
that's why i've only written about
washington in my novels and so you know
i've done the 70s i've done the 80s and
90s and i and i've it's always been a
not not a political in the sense of like
you know who the mayor is and stuff but
political in the sense of why things are
the way they are
i'm really interested in why things work
the way they do and how people get
crushed by
the system yeah when it's working
against them
um you brought up barry um
i'll probably get hate mail for this but
you know you all you always do but when
you bring up his name because people are
so passionate about it but you know he's
the best mayor of the city ever had
and on one side he was a great mayor on
the other side he was a human being who
had who had faults
and um
you know he created a black middle class
here in a lot of ways there was always
there was always an upper uh class black
population here
harlem renaissance we had our own harlem
renaissance in the in the 20s and
there was always that and dunbar high
school and so on
but
barry created a black middle class how
did he i mean i've heard people say that
jobs
government jobs he created not only
government jobs
summer jobs for kids summer jobs program
yeah i i had one my first job
at you know
outside of my bed diner yeah i worked
for the rec department dollar sixty an
hour that was a summer jobs program
and and every you each talked to
washingtonians my age and they almost
all of them say i got my first job
because mayor and barry yeah not only
that he built all sorts of um
senior living facilities for people east
of
rock creek park and east of the river
where there wasn't where there was none
but people always want to get throw
shade on them and and even you know i'll
tell you a story like i did i did a
a script
for based on his life that i was
commissioned to do
and the guy that was the studio guy that
was giving me notes kept coming back to
the same thing but why did he do it why
did he you know why did he smoke crack
why was he why was he chasing women and
you know this went on for months and
months
and finally i said i said to the guy i
said because he wanted me to go back and
say did he have daddy issues and what
happened was i said you know
he liked power and he liked [ __ ] you
know what i mean like that's just that
and he was a great mayor why can't you
deal with that yeah yeah yeah you know
he was human being everyone i mean
everyone knew he was doing that right i
mean like that wasn't a surprise right
like yeah just like kennedy yeah i mean
everyone knew he everyone i mean i
remember like being a little boy and my
dad was like yeah mayor berry you know i
mean it's prostitutes and like like like
it was just kind of like a known well it
was it was tragic because he was so
bright and did so many good things it
was tragic on a personal level
but i don't know why people took it
personally like why they hated him so
much do you think len bias plays a a
role in that
uh well you know i wrote a book the
sweet forever which takes place over the
um the the uh ncaa the tournament and
then his death it ends in his death and
what it meant it meant so much to
washingtonians i know that you must know
a lot of people who stopped doing coke
after 11 months
a lot of people i mean i was a little
boy but i it's one you know that and
when the challenger blew up and when
mayor barry got you know was on tv you
know smoking that bite the landmarks
but like those are the yeah i remember
exactly i mean i was little you know
under 10 but i remember exactly where i
was when each three of those things
happened and lem bias was just like
could couldn't you know
stopped us all on our tracks we were
like what yeah i mean i look i still
have a picture of him in my office some
office wall palming those two
basketballs like
and i saw him play he he was as good as
jordan in my in my opinion he would what
a you know what a waste like had they
played together yeah
in the nba yeah i saw him you know
he was incredible man yeah all he was
was a young guy who was celebrating he
wasn't a co-cut or anything like that
he he just did too much on one at one
sitting he was celebrating he just got
signed to the nba you know you know i've
been kind of connected to you since the
day i've met you and i admire you and
look up to you
for a [ __ ] ton of reasons which i want
to get into but i admire you too john
thanks george
but like no man it's [ __ ] anyway
but like but but you know growing up in
a city like this in a predominantly
black city
the
the hypocrisy it's just like it's like
right in your face all the time and i
really really felt it
both out like in the way that the you
know i got in trouble with the law
uh you know quite a bit and and that
same thing it really like really
affected me how
i oh and
it didn't make me say hey i'm not gonna
go run to my dad hey i'm not gonna go
run and get all the help that i can and
my old man was like by all means
necessary we are gonna like try with
whatever we can to keep you out of the
system but at the same time
it was never lost on either one of us
how how ridiculously [ __ ] unfair that
is
but even right here in this school
you know i
was a terrible kid and a terrible
troublemaker but somehow
i you know i graduated from this place
and i i have you know
many dear you know black brothers who
who got thrown out and who did do far
less you know and and i feel like that
hypocrisy has really shaped like it's
just shaped me in so many different ways
and i'm wondering whether like when you
say you see len bias like the narrative
was here's another
you know
black
you know drug addict and the crack
epidemic and the war on you know
that's not what happened
not at all right but like is that do you
think that that is
unique to you being
a dc guy
that you understood that
uh i i don't know i i just think it's
your tote the totality of your life
experience make shapes how you look at
people and things you know
um
i mean
watching uh your interview with natalie
something
stood out to me that she was talking
about how
you can't just judge people on their on
their politics or even their
even their uh racial politics like i'll
give you an example like my kids uh like
my sons you know my sons are black and
all my kids are adopted so they they got
to be friends with these guys when they
were growing up who whose father was
pretty you know rough around the edges
and i knew he
uh
just in talking to him i knew he had you
know like problems with black people and
stuff like that he's way older than i am
so he grew up in the 50s
very tough guy
but i didn't stop being friends with him
or anything like that and i didn't it
wasn't like i didn't want my kids around
him and when i when my kids were with
him
like if they if he took them out to
mcdonald's or something like that or to
drove them to football practice
i felt like he would they were safer
with him
than they were with any of the liberal
guys i knew in the neighborhood because
if any [ __ ] went down he'd take a bullet
for my kids that's right even though
even though he had racial problems in
his in his head
he loved my kids you know and
he was tough enough to
to defend him if he had to yep and he
would yep
yep so you know don't you know like just
because somebody plants a black lives
matter flag
in their
yard it doesn't really mean anything to
me yeah i'm i'm i'm with you there man
i'm with you there and and uh to
tell me just a bit about i mean like
you know your choice your choice and
your decision to write like how that
came about and i imagine it's all
connected but um your first novel is
firing offense yeah you know and that's
there's like i know a lot a little bit
of that is like the dc like kind of like
hardcore scene the punk rock scene yeah
were you into that scene or yeah
i was like 930 club and fugazi and bad
brains yeah i know a bunch of those guys
and they're all my they're all my
generation it was a big thing but also
in washington the um
they were hooked up like you used to go
they'd sometimes have shows with go-go
bands
and they were really trying to get black
kids and white kids to to be together
yeah
and we we would be together not in the
it didn't work in the larger sense like
it's it's not like we were then out that
night we were over in southeast or
something yeah hanging out
but for that afternoon we were right and
it was a real the punk rock thing in
washington was a very positive thing
it's positive force yep
it wasn't like the scenes in the other
cities where there was a lot of violence
and drugs and stuff like that it was a
it was a good thing yep yep so that was
a big that was a big deal yeah what led
you to write that book and like what
what got you into writing i just had
this one story in my head that i always
wanted to write i only wanted to write
one book
to uh did the this is going to sound
corny but to prove that i was here that
i existed you know i always thought well
if i could have a book in a library yeah
after i'm gone a hundred years from now
and
and my name's on that book it meant that
i was here you know that i did something
so you knew when you were writing you
were like this is gonna get i want to
get this published and i want to get it
out to the world i didn't know [ __ ] i
was i had never written anything before
i just had a i had a feeling that i
could do it
and that's what you saw the totality of
the story or you i knew i could tell the
story i didn't know how to write a book
i never took a writing class i didn't
know any agents i didn't know any other
writers i had no connection to anything
i did it and i sent it up to new york
and i forgot about it
i sent it up to a publisher one
publisher in new york randomly
i knew they published a lot of crime
novels
and i and i just didn't i didn't call
them or anything
or write them and then a year later they
called me and they said we just picked
us up off the
slush pile
and we want to publish it
that's what happened and in that proc in
that year did you write anything else i
started writing another book because i
liked it yeah and and why did you stay
why why stay in crime why stay in dc i
think the the crime thing
was gave me an engine to a narrative
engine
i don't i don't know how to write a book
where people are just talking about
their feelings yeah [ __ ] has to happen
yeah yeah it's got to be conflict and
yeah
conflict is i mean drama is conflict
right and then life and death is the
highest form of conflict so
crime
and then the crime thing allowed me to
go to the other side of town which
hadn't been written about and you know
there was no writers writing about any
any washington novels except for
politics and spies yeah
yeah
and and now i mean now of course there
are i mean look you've got ed jones
which i think he's the greatest writer
edward p jones the greatest writer who's
ever come out of washington
he went to cardozo
dc public school yeah
i mean
and i mean some would argue that that
that that you are but yeah i hear you oh
only you yeah i don't know about that
but but but uh uh
tell me a little bit about um just like
truth and research
and um i know why truth is so important
to me i know what like i know what it
like kind of does for me of like
finding the real story having that and
and diving into that what what is it
what is it for you like what what why
are you i mean on set with you know you
and you and david
you know you you guys know what the [ __ ]
you're doing and you you know you like
things a certain way
but if something really happened a
certain way that always
wins the day and i'm just wondering why
i i'm wondering what that means to you
i i just you know i think if you if
you're gonna write about uh or make a
show about people and and especially
people
in the neighborhoods you know when i say
in the neighborhoods like locals that
don't have a lot and and don't get
written about a lot i mean that's the
thing is like i i felt like first of all
i'm gonna write about stuff that doesn't
normally get rid people that don't
normally get their their
place in the light you know
because american novels are mostly about
people who succeed
they're not i i want to write books
about like a guy who's a dishwasher in a
kitchen
and at the end of the book he's still a
dishwasher
but he
he lived his life a certain way you know
what i mean yeah but if you're gonna do
that you need to respect people
especially what you haven't said but a
white writer writing black characters
sure as hell needs to respect people
enough to go out there and and listen to
people and and
and uh and and get involved you know and
then and
not in their lives but
to to
[Music]
to get the voices right
how does that train like
is it the same acro like when you go and
you do it in dc because i've seen how
you are on set and i've seen how you are
about the truth and i've seen how you
are about your your research and just
the respect
you know it's that's [ __ ] pot calling
the kettle black because when you came
to baltimore you completely immersed
yourself in that in what you
what you were portraying and you brought
stuff to set that we didn't know
in fact one of my
best memories of this show is when
somebody said that
somebody came into the courtroom and
said that
your character jenkins wouldn't be
wearing that in court and you just
casually on your phone showed a picture
of jenkins in court wearing that very
outfit
and i'll never forget it because you did
the you did the research you knew
exactly
what you were going to be doing that day
you know you know i i guess for me
though man i i feel like i ha if i don't
do that i'm [ __ ] lost as [ __ ] yeah
but nobody told you to do that like
you uh brought a lot to the show in a
lot of ways but also
you knew the character better than uh
and sometimes better than in some ways
better than we knew it after researching
it for two years
and
and you did all that on your own which i
really um
i'm really thankful for well look i
appreciate i appreciate you saying that
like i didn't i didn't set you up to go
riding with these guys and and
and hang out with the police and go on
rides and this and that i i didn't do
that yeah you didn't you know for me
it's like yeah there's no question i
think we're the we're the same we have
the same relationship with it that it's
got to be about respect like if you're
going to do that if you're going to put
that uniform on if you're going to like
put right you know if you're going to if
you're going to put
you know pen to page and you're going to
say i'm telling your story if if you're
finding the truth
you've got to show that respect you know
it would be disrespectful for i think
people think that our it's just that
it's up you you know that you've got to
like create it it's like man you got to
do the [ __ ] work and you got to find
out what that is
and i hear what you're saying about like
the respect and and look i think you got
to kind of love what you you got to love
the story you're telling and you got you
got to find something but for me a lot
of it also is uh
is fear man i'm i'm scared shitless when
when i'm making something and the only
thing i can like absolutely rely on is
if you give me a situation where i say
where okay at least we're going after
truth like that's our sword it's truth
like we're gonna go try to get this
right and tell the story like it
actually happened then it's
you actually have a north star you
actually have something that you can
follow
and and for me it's just it's the only
it's it's the only thing that kind of
calms my nerves but you just seem like
so steady you know what i mean like like
like do you get nervous about this [ __ ]
well i'm nervous in the sense that
my my fear is that somebody's gonna
watch
a show i did in baltimore a baltimorean
or washingtonian is going to read one of
my books and say that's [ __ ] mm-hmm
he didn't do his research totally
it's a lie really you're a chump that's
all i care about i don't care about uh
what they think in la or new york or
anything unless i'm shooting a show in
l.a about l.a about l.a yeah yeah and so
is that also you know you made the wire
a lot of people like me think it's the
best show in the history of television
you know painted a picture that you know
people hadn't really seen before and and
you know look you guys
you know you guys use pat moran you guys
use local casting you guys filled the
the the piece with locals is that that
same
because there's also a side to you that
you know nobody knows but i know it and
that's just like
you know man you have a huge heart and
the truth is i mean you know you made
all these shows but you've been making
them with the same crew
and
those crews they love you man those
crews are there because of you because
of how you treat people because how you
treat the community
yeah i mean that's just true right and
that's they don't feel that way about
everybody you know what i'm saying yeah
and like they definitely don't like
[ __ ] are there for you and
i'm just wondering like when you
you know obviously they're that that's a
hit or miss thing when you're you're
putting people in tv shows you know
you're you're putting people from the
streets to play to play parts that are
closer it's a little more challenging
because you can get a dud once in a
while but and then you just did it i
mean you know that
like the guys that you were that guy you
were interrogating and that when we shot
in that school yeah he was in federal
prison right and he walked to work from
his public housing which was right up
the street that day he walked to set
that's one of the best actors we had on
that show so i couldn't ask for anything
more couldn't i and you can't get that
you can't get that from uh
casting up in new york and stuff like
that that's right but you you also don't
get the same uh
consistency so you have it is a
challenge you know what i mean so i
understand why when that works how that
le that that that that lens a layer of
authenticity you know like like the wire
like what we're doing right now there's
a layer of authenticity that you can't
get that anywhere else because you're
populating it with the real people and i
get that like there's that authenticity
that you're after that truth that you're
after but as part of it also um
it's just kind of being respectful and
being um
kind of uh
paying paying reverence to the city
you're in by bringing those folks and
employment i mean i really couldn't
i couldn't wait to get back to baltimore
to to
to do what you're talking about which is
because they need it man like that city
needs it yeah i mean they need jobs but
also um
a lot of those people we we met
way back you know in the wire for
example that are like dejuan in the
costumes you know he was a kid that was
hanging around set and we eventually
gave him a job and now he's pretty far
up in the in one of the departments and
um
all our security guys are
yeah
you know you've positively uh impacted
their lives but they did the same for me
right i really like um production
and i like it because i you know when i
get out of the van in the morning and
there's a hundred people there the crew
i feel really good it's like all right
we're gonna make something together
today
and i think they're all in their own way
they're
they're all craftsmen but a lot of them
are real artists too they're no
i'm not a bigger artist than they are
just because i wrote the thing yeah
they're and i can't do you know it's
just words on a page
until everybody makes it everybody gets
together and makes it that's it i i like
that you know that's the aspect of it i
like more than anything where
when i'm writing a novel
it's all mine my name's on it you know i
i get more of the um
more the more the love like you know
what i mean the ego stuff
but it's not as fun yeah i like hanging
out with people yeah yeah you're there
man i mean you're in it and and uh you
know one of the things that i like most
about this production that we just did
is just seeing you there with nick you
know like sitting there with with your
with your son and just how like just
that relationship and
you know i could see in your eyes you
know you're looking at you're like
that's your son man and that's just so
you know i'm a dad obviously i'm real
close to my dad i know how much your dad
means
to you you know what i mean uh
it'll it'll mean a lot to my other son
pete works
on the show too he's in the art
department and
it'll mean a lot to them later on i
think it means something to them now but
i know that
i it was a great gift for me to be able
to work with my dad growing up
and see him
see a man what's what a man supposed to
do
which is to go to work every day yeah
and my father was never happier than
when he was turning the key on his
business every morning and he was never
happier than when he was at work
and i i have i do the same thing as far
as i'm concerned i have an office at
home and
every day at nine o'clock i walk in
there and open the door to my business
you know yeah yeah it's mine yeah and
that's what i learned from my father
yeah what would you say just sort of
like about
kind of being a dad i mean your
your kids are older and and uh what are
the hardest things about it what are
what what are the the best things about
it
it's mostly good
i mean it's
i'm so uh thankful that i that i did it
and um and i'm continue to be their
father you know i will for the rest of
my life
and you know
we and as far as like the adoption thing
i have to quote to credit my wife
because
we uh wanted a family and um you know we
were having trouble getting pregnant and
all that stuff and then my wife was
adopted and finally um i i said and she
had a
great life
i mean her parents are our parents
that's
absolutely so i finally said to her why
are we [ __ ] around with all this
fertility stuff let's let's adopt adopt
some kids
so we went to the thing you know the
lawyer
and it's a really weird process i think
it is you know they
they they put a bunch of pictures out in
front of you and and it's like an array
of photos and all these babies and
and they say you know like basically
they say choose one well in in choosing
one
you're you're rejecting the other ones
like you know
there's
what you're going to do for somebody by
taking them out of that situation which
is usually you know
a negative situation
is is a great is a good thing you know
what i mean but the other kids aren't
going to have that experience and stuff
like that so
we went to the um
we were in the meeting with the lawyers
and and they and they said to us what
kind of baby do you want
and i didn't know how to answer well i
did say i said what do you mean what
kind of baby you mean like what color
yeah baby i didn't know how to answer
i'm just a dumb guy i want to be i want
a son who looks like me you know curly
hair big nose
greek
and
and uh so i didn't i didn't know what to
say
my wife goes um
we want whoever needs to be adopted
like leave it to a woman that just like
cut through all the [ __ ] and say say
the right thing you know
and that's how i got my kids wow and it
was easy it was it was easy because we
weren't trying to get a uh
a white kid yeah like when nick came to
us it was like right after our home
study it was like a few months after we
started the process they called us up
and they said there's a baby coming up
from brazil
and and do you want him
we didn't have anything we didn't have a
crib we didn't have anything man we when
i went to the office to get him
he was wrapped up in the airline blanket
um
from the from brazil air or whatever it
is
and they
they put them in my arms and i'm not
kidding you man as soon as they put them
in my arms i was his father
[ __ ] nick man
and how about nick man like like his
whole journey like you know like he was
an athlete and uh really good he went
into matha he played football he
wrestled and all but
he he got thrown out of the math oh
diddy yeah and and i know he had gotten
into some trouble well he got into real
big trouble when he was 18 like
looking at prison kind of trouble yeah
what was that like for you it was awful
but i it was awful and i and
um but having been sort of down that
road myself
i knew that it wasn't the end
and um
he lucked out too and i think it's
because i'm his father in other words we
went to court and the judge knew who i
was
he had read my books and and he had seen
the wire the wire was
still on at the time or was it was a
little it was just after was over but he
had seen it he knew who i was
and he gave my son probation
instead of sending him to uh to prison
so
that's another example right
of what we talked about in the beginning
of this interview yeah
and i took him down to new orleans with
me to work on the show treme was that
the first first set he had really worked
on yeah okay
he was 18.
and uh he's been he's 30. he's been in
the business 12 years director now he's
a director the killer man yeah
that's awesome that's awesome yeah
um
right on man do you uh is there is there
anything else you wanna you wanna talk
about here today
i didn't know what i was doing you know
when i was writing these books i really
didn't i kind of learned it on the job
and i thought well wouldn't it be cool
this this kind of this world that i
started in the first couple of books
it's a real world to me it's watching
everyone's real right i mean everyone's
based on someone real no not everybody
but but i felt like why can't these guys
walk through other books um and appear
in other books because it's washington
it's a pretty small town what else you
want to do george like what it what what
do you want to do man i don't know i
mean there's so much there's so much i
want to write about i want to make a
western uh i always wanted to make a
western and uh there's more books i'm
going to be working
um
you know it's funny i i had uh
you know this i had a health scare
earlier this year and
i had a tumor you know i had a malignant
tumor that i had an operation they took
it
out and but the first thing i thought
about when i got the diagnosis was not
like
well i wish i had climbed mount everest
or i'd done this or gone to the
galapagos islands or something it's like
wait a minute i'm not done yet like what
about all the books i haven't written
and what about
the movies i haven't made and stuff like
that and
i'm to be keep working until my death i
mean there's no retirement for me i just
keep working
that's what i look forward to yeah
you can't revise a blank piece of paper
right
so
right now man yep tomato here's this is
the man right here
it was such a pleasure working with you
man man never forget it yeah i i feel
the same way man honestly it's like you
i it was uh
that that that one was was special but
you know
what i said you know
that that i've never met so many
beautiful people on
a set and on a project like beautiful
righteous amazing people and every
single one of those beautiful people was
there because of you you like me because
they believe in you and what you're
about and
like you know that you walk that walk so
yeah man i uh i really appreciate you
man all right thank you yeah meet you
thank you
man all right guys thank you thank you
everybody
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff it'd mean a lot to us
i hope you dig these episodes as much as
we dig doing them you guys take care of
yourself